all right people
this is it
this is my last live stream before
officially going off the grid
for all of august it is true
that tomorrow is technically the last
day of july tomorrow is july 31st but it
is a saturday
so i'm getting a bonus day tonight
at midnight that will be it i'm wrapping
up a couple things today
obviously some live streams i'm doing
some stuff on oan later on fox on
newsmax couple other media hits it's a
big day
and then i disappear off the grid
no phone no tv no news
no current events no twitter trolls no
bots
no nothing uh in many ways this is the
very moment right now that i sort of
planned for the entire year we
bust our butts obviously not only here
at the reuben report
but everything we're doing with
locals.com we work real hard throughout
the year
to do this and it's by the way not just
me going fully off the grid
obviously david's coming off the grid
with me but my team gets to relax and
unwind we've got some projects that
everybody's going to be doing but i
try to do this so that all the people
that i work with and who work for me are
able
to relax to enjoy life to enjoy the
summer
to get a little mental space a little
little
physical restoration um so i'm
incredibly excited you know this is
obviously a very
weird year to be doing it because the
news of the last few days and now with
impending
seemingly impending lockdowns coming and
so much more it's like who the hell
knows
what's going to happen by the time i get
back in september but i want to make a
couple
announcements we are going to do a
two-hour live stream today
uh we're not doing any news we're going
to do some q a
i want to talk to you about my new book
which really is that's the real thing of
the day
and some locals announcements that i've
been teasing
but something absolutely insane happened
last night i suspect most of you know
about it
already but i got into the news
accidentally because i told the truth
and you know the thing is if you tell
the truth in a time of lies
the powers that be don't like that very
much so last night
i was on uh hannity although judge
jeanine was guest hosting for sean
i was on it about halfway through the
show and
we were actually talking about the
southern border and what's going on down
there
and i said something to the effect of
you know well basically
because we have a democratic
administration it's like what was bad
under trump is now good under them but
the bigger issue is that the media just
won't cover it right because we see now
if you're online you're seeing it
all of these people just wandering
through our southern border some of them
have masks some of them don't they're
not even all from mexico which is
obviously our mexican
american border many of them are from
haiti and all sorts of other countries
they're not social distancing it turns
out that lots of them actually do have
covet there was another report yesterday
that about 50 000 people have all been
sent into the country they're going all
over the place and they're supposed to
report back to ice but guys you're not
going to believe this they're not
doing it only about 12 percent or so are
actually reporting back dice so anyway i
was saying that you know in in effect
because we have a democratic
administration with the mainstream media
that's all lefties and democrats
liberals whatever you want to say
uh fueled by big tech that we just can't
get anything true
true information cannot get out there
that's in effect what i said
when i was on air with judge jeanine and
then when we uh
got off air connor my director here
handed me my phone and i
looked down and i was locked out of
twitter
so the adventure began so why was i
locked out of twitter
well why don't we pull up the first
image here
uh twitter here's the yeah okay so we're
gonna do it that way
so here's the the message that i got
from twitter is what you're seeing on
the left
we've temporarily limited some of your
account features
what happened we've determined that this
account violated the twitter rules
specifically for
and here's the key part violating the
policy on spreading
misleading and potentially harmful
information related to covet 19.
okay so come back to me real quick so
before i read you the tweet
obviously what i was talking about on
judge union wasn't specifically related
to covid it was ancillarily related to
covert right because we're letting all
of these people in they don't have mass
no social distancing we're told that
there's a pandemic
and we're sending them throughout the
country so maybe that's spreading a
little bit of covet
and i'm not a scientist and i'm just a
regular guy i don't know um
but then they linked me to the tweet
that i had sent
out earlier in the day and i'm going to
read the tweet for you and you tell me
if i'm spreading
misinformation with this tweet they want
a federal vaccine mandate for vaccines
which are clearly not
working as promised just weeks ago
people are getting and transmitting
kovid despite the vaccination
plus now they're prepping us for booster
shots a sane society would take a pause
we do not live in a sane
when i saw that message then you have
two options twitter gives you two
options
one option is you can just delete the
tweet and then you're in a twitter
timeout
for 12 hours and they actually give you
a countdown clock like you're about to
launch a nuclear weapon
you can do that or they say you can
fight it you can submit another form to
fight it but they don't give you a time
frame
on when that might happen now because i
knew that today was obviously
a huge day for us because i'm debuting
uh my new book which we're going to get
to in just a moment and because it's my
off the great live stream i didn't want
to risk just being in twitter purgatory
because these companies have
extraordinary power over us our ability
to communicate with each other
so i clicked the delete tweet but i was
not happy about it because what i
said in that tweet was absolutely true
so how do i know it's true or how do i
know it's acceptable narrative at the
very least right i'll put aside true for
a moment
well i went back in i went back into the
internet and i got headlines from usa
today
and from cnn and from washington post
all saying the exact same things
that i said in that tweet yesterday so
first
what i said was they want a federal
vaccine mandate for vaccines which are
clearly not working
as promised a few weeks ago usa today
yesterday an american tragedy biden
offers incentives
mandates to get 90 million holdouts to
vaccine and there is video
yesterday of biden talking about whether
the justice department is going to have
to look into whether you could do a
federal
mass mandate so a federal vaccine
mandate okay so number one my first
point
absolutely true the second point was
that
vaccines are not working as promised
just a few weeks ago washington post
yesterday walter a orenstein associate
director of the emory vaccine center
said he was struck by
data showing that vaccinated people who
became infected with delta
shed just as much virus as those who
were not vaccinated
so the vaccine not working as promised
that's all i said here we've got a
scientifician saying it in the
washington post
and then finally i said they're prepping
us for booster shots now we know this
everyone's talking about this now that
in a
you know a few months after you get your
second job they're going to want you to
get another job and people are even
talking about
would they want us to get monthly jabs
or what else is going to happen well cnn
pfizer data suggests third dose of
covid19 vaccine strongly boosts
protection
against the delta variant yes so they
want you to get booster shots
not only were was everything that i said
in that tweet true
but the end of what i said could we pull
up my original tweet again for just a
sec the end of what i said was
a sane society would take a pause
we do not live in a sane society
the reason i wrote it that way was i am
trying to de-escalate the madness i
think you guys see what i do
on this show what i've actually
basically at this point devoted my
entire life to
is de-escalating the madness trying to
clarify
some of the confusion trying to sift
through the lies etc etc that is what
i'm trying to do here i'm not trying to
do much more than that
if i could get that done that would be
pretty good i think that would be
retirement worthy right
um so the idea that i was spreading this
information if i'm spreading this
information well then you got to ban cnn
you got a ban on washington post and you
got banned usa today i'm not really
against those things
but that's what you would have to do now
a beautiful thing happened when i got
that
email saying that i was suspended um i
created a tech company
did you guys know about that i created
this tech company called locals.com
and uh we have several hundred thousand
people in the reuben report community
that are that are not all paying members
you obviously have to pay a couple bucks
if you want to interact with all of our
content we have many thousands of people
that are doing that but i was able to
then live stream directly from my phone
i was able to send push notifications to
people i was able to live
chat with people and that's what i've
been talking about this entire time that
we need
off ramps they could take any of us out
you watching this on youtube right now
they could take down my account they
could take down your account
you tweeting about this they can take
you out they can
shadowband you they can silence you et
cetera et cetera so in many ways what
happened last night leading into today
which is my big day of the year is
exactly
sort of my life just kind of lining up
in a in a sort of perfectly sweet and
oddly perverse way i would say
so i was able to communicate with all of
my people which was
really just great or anyone that joins
us at locals obviously
uh then i want to give a special shout
out actually to some of the people
i started texting people that are still
on twitter and saying guys can you
amplify this i've been suspended so i
want to give a
shout out to jack bosovic who is huge
and kyle kashuv and bridget fedezi
and ron coleman and a bunch of the
people at post millennial
and melissa chen and a whole bunch of
people that you know from this show that
did
actually promote what was happening to
me that
that risk themselves putting screenshots
out there
um because it is a risk to themselves
and i appreciate people that stick their
neck out
uh for other people i do it for other
people all the time and it's nice to see
when it's reciprocated
um anyway i went to bed i was banned
from twitter and i thought boy this is
sort of ironic i'm about to go off the
grid for a month and i'm getting banned
from twitter the day before suspended
from twitter the day before like this is
kind of
kind of fitting and by the way it also
felt sort of like pleasant i was like
well twitter's horrible i talk about how
horrible it is all the time
like maybe that maybe maybe the good
lord is sending me a sign you know like
maybe something's going on here
then about an hour ago you're not going
to believe this guys so i was reinstated
this morning the 12 hours expired the
countdown hit zero no no bombs went off
and then you're not going to believe it
pull up the image i got
this email from the twitter people
and i'll read it for you hello we have
restored your account
and we apologized for any inconvenience
this may have caused
twitter takes reports of violations of
the twitter rules very seriously
after reviewing your account it looks
like we made an error
thanks twitter support
wait a minute wait a minute let me get
that other piece of paper here
before can we put up the original thing
that they said that i did i was a
that was misinformation i could have
been killing people
but then can we get the apology again
well gosh darn it
it looks like they made an error and not
only did they make an error
but i've got the receipts to prove it
cnn
washington post usa today i'm gonna go
off the grid with a terrible paper cut
that's what's going to happen here today
um anyway this is exactly why i created
locals
and this is just a special shout out to
those of you that that support me there
this is just the beginning i'm going to
make some announcements to local about
locals in just a second
but putting all of that aside because
that is not why i
intended on doing this big live stream
today and it was just like a little
wrinkle in time that
that occurred right before our big day
here uh the main reason i'm doing this
big live stream today
is that because i'm going off the grid
today we planned and plotted
and arranged everything that my new book
could be announced
for pre-sale today so my new book
are we going to show it i'm going to i'm
going to there we go there's an image
my new book don't burn this country is
available for pre-sale now yesterday we
were
uh on locals we had a couple people
guessing what the title might be we said
don't burn then people had to guess
people thought this constitution
you know some other stuff this youtuber
et cetera et cetera but my new book
don't burn this country surviving and
thriving in our woke dystopia
is up for pre-sale today so what i'm
doing today
the book will be out on april 12th 2022
the publishing world is just sort of
a slow slog we still have a little bit
of editing we're going to do
i actually i'm going to change the intro
to the book to talk about what happened
on twitter because it's
it's a perfect example of exactly what
this book is about
but what we are doing today is i want to
sign book plates for every
single copy bought today
if i have to go off the grid with a
crippled hand if my hand at the end of
the day
i got like the claw hand i will be happy
to do it if we sell 10 000 copies today
i will spend the rest of my day going
through my sharpies
and signing book plates so you can buy
the book right now for pre-sale
at don'tburnthiscountry.com that's going
to direct you to the penguin site where
you can pick which retailer so you can
do amazon obviously barnes and noble et
cetera et cetera
and then we've got a little form which
is in this youtube description right now
and all you got to do is fill that out
show us that you bought the book and i
will
sign the uh book plate for you today
and our locals members as you guys know
because i did a live stream
exclusive to you guys this morning
locals members are getting
signed and numbered copies so anyone
that joins locals today i will also i
can do a signed and numbered copy so
this is the book plate
these are numbered down here but if you
don't want to join us on locals
you're a loss however don't burn this uh
don't burn this country
you go to don't burn this book.com too i
think there's something going on over
there buy that one it's pretty good
but don't burn this country.com buy the
book
and then i want to sign as many as i as
i can today and i'm i'm incredibly
excited to be uh
sharing this book with you guys and as i
said i'll make a few little changes and
i want to change something at the
at the top right now just because of
what happened here
but it really is the next step
in some ways i now see don't burn this
thing as a trilogy right so we had don't
burn this book don't burn this country
what could be the next one but i really
am seeing it as a trilogy now because in
don't burn this book what i did
was lay out what my beliefs are i
believe and i still believe this to this
day
that my classically liberal principles
the idea of individual rights and logic
and reason and limited government and
laissez-faire economics what are thought
of really as modern conservative
principles
because i also talk about uh why belief
is important
as an as an under guard for all of those
things
that is the right lens to look at a free
society through and to build a free
society
this book is about the things that you
can do to make sure
as the as the subtitle says that you can
not only survive but thrive i want
people to survive
and thrive not just survive these
lockdowns and mask mandates and getting
jabbed and being lied to all the time
i want you to thrive in it because i've
managed to thrive thankfully
but it's not by accident maybe it's with
a little bit of luck but it's because i
navigated this thing
properly i made the right business
decisions i i took risks
and that really is what this book is
about being less reliant on the system
being less reliant on big tech on big
government
on big pharma all of those things that
really is what this is all about and
speaking
of being less reliant on big tech i've
also been teasing that we have a couple
big announcements related to locals so
all of you guys know this i started
locals about two years ago because it
was very obvious
that big tech was coming for all of us
it what happened to me yesterday on
twitter the only reason they're sending
me that
email and and retracting it is because i
am popular enough i have enough of a
voice
in essence to make a headache for them
otherwise
if i was just a random person i'm sure
my account just would have been blown up
period they wouldn't have even done the
12-hour suspension they would have just
blown it up
we know that if you talk about certain
things on youtube they can just blow up
your channel immediately we had to
censor part of our interview with
president trump i put the full thing
up over at locals.com so we all know
that there are these huge problems and
the problems are just getting worse
because mainstream and corporate media
and big tech we know they're colluding
with each other right we know
saki's own words not mine they the
administration is flagging posts
for facebook violation of the first
amendment and i hope they get sued into
oblivion
saki also said that if you get banned on
one thing you should be banned on also
had twitter
banned me yesterday instead of done this
temporary suspension should i have been
banned on youtube and facebook and
everywhere else
so it was obvious it was just obvious to
me that i had to build something for
myself
and it's been a lot of work we've built
absolutely everything ourselves we own
everything we wrote the code it's all
ours
we are working on all sorts of stuff
related to decentralized storage and
payments and all of the issues that you
guys know about and no
we have not solved everything but we
have solved a lot of them and we are
working on
all of the other stuff i promise you so
that all being said i am thrilled
to finally be able to announce to you
guys a couple things right now
so number one and this is this is the
most important one
you guys all know about rumble at this
point so rumble is really the only
youtube competitor at this point okay
this is where a lot of people are now
posting their videos so that they aren't
under the thumb
of youtube censorship well we've been
talking to rumble for a long time i
really love the team over there chris
who's running the thing is just
absolutely spectacular fully gets it
at an ideal level and a technology level
and we've been working with him and the
team there for quite some time i'm
putting a partnership together
and i am thrilled i'm truly thrilled to
announce
that locals will be the official
subscription
partner of rumble so rumble
which is where you put all your videos
and it's got great search and they're
not manipulating stuff and it is much
more in line with my free speech values
and i'm sure your free speech values as
well
every single rumble creator will have a
button so that they can create
a locals community so we are the
subscription partner
so the goal i'm telling you right now we
are coming for you big tech the goal is
rumble will replace youtube the goal is
locals will replace patreon
and this is just the beginning rumble
also has the infrastructure to allow
locals to scale in the way that we want
to scale right because you want to scale
you want to just keep growing and
growing and growing and growing
and we've done a great job on our own
but we're gonna we're gonna tie those
knots a little bit more
and uh and it's gonna be a beautiful
thing i have no doubt about it
uh and just a couple other things on the
locals front uh we have tv apps coming
soon apple tv
roku tv we're in beta testing my locals
community
right now we have several members in
there that are helping us beta test it
but tv apps coming soon again to make us
less reliant
on just oh if we get kicked off youtube
we're in a lot of trouble now we can be
on these tv apps as well
there could be more related to that stay
tuned perhaps live streaming on those
things my god is that doable holy cow
uh also charlie kirk you guys know
charlie kirk from turning point usa he
launched his locals community this
morning and just in the last
half hour or so i've been given
clearance on this one
candace owens who has changed the world
probably like if you look at the top 10
people from an american perspective
who've changed the world in the last
five years
candace is in that group somewhere
candace owens
is now launching her locals community i
believe it will be up today maybe up in
the next couple days they were just
working on
some technical stuff but we are growing
we are growing fast we're going to
announce some other acquisitions
just a lot of cool stuff and i just
thank you guys for helping me
helping me just be on this road to do
this thing we've got the right investors
right now we've got the right
uh team we built the team ourselves it's
awesome as you know we move the company
down to
down to miami so lots of good things
happening oh and i am told
not bad guys don't burn this country is
now number two in
amazon's movers and shakers category can
we get this thing to number one while
i'm doing a live stream the book isn't
even out
until april let's show the powers that
be what is what
okay let's get this thing to number one
in movers and shakers we're already at
number two that's awesome the book's
not even out for six months everybody
everybody else is selling books that are
out
we pre-sell books are out here okay uh
all right so i'm going to do a bunch of
q a right now taking questions from
reubenreport.locals.com so you can jump
in right now
you can download our ios app you can
download our android app at the google
play store or you can just go on desktop
reubenreport.locals.com
i will answer all your questions happy
to talk about the book happy to talk
about locals happy to talk about the
twitter nonsense happy to talk about
going off the grid
happy to talk about the forum on
shooting a nice three
whatever you want to talk about that's
what we're going to talk about so here
we go guys
uh bradford says i'm guessing that
liberty's crown is what's burning on the
cover of the book
how did you come up with that cover so
yes that is true can we why don't we
throw up the image right there
that is liberty's crown we had a couple
different versions of this that we were
we were going for the funny thing about
the book is that
i actually originally wanted don't burn
this country like when i
when i fully agreed with penguin that i
was going to do another book immediately
i was like well it was don't burn this
country
and then for a second it was more of a
joke i was like well why don't we call
it
don't burn the store that this book is
in because obviously the targets were
burning and everything else
they kind of liked that but it was
obviously a little wordy so then the
next version was all right don't burn
this book now don't burn this country
and as i said if this is the middle one
if this is the empire strikes back of
the trilogy
i think you can probably figure out
perhaps what the what the final one will
most likely be called
uh but then you know when you're when
you're working with the big publishing
house and the people at penguin have
been great to us and a special shout out
to my editor helen who uh as i said on
the locals live stream
this morning probably knows me better
than i know myself at some level and has
really been
uh instrumental i can't overstate in
helping me piece to this together and
getting the ideas right and
understanding
understanding my voice even at times
when i'm writing something and i'm not
even totally
totally sure where it's going she can
always kind of bump me in the right
direction
but there's a big team there and you go
back and forth you go back and forth
about title
you go back and forth about what the
flames are going to look like and we had
one version without
the statue of liberty we had one version
where it was the statue of liberty's
torch and the flame was coming out of
that
we had other versions all together you
know i really wanted the word dystopian
or dystopia in the subtitle
so it's surviving and thriving in our
woke dystopia
i really like the word thriving too
because it's not just
that i want you guys to survive it's i
don't want you to just get by
right now too many people are just
getting by you just wake up and it's
another day
and you didn't do anything yesterday and
you're not going to do anything tomorrow
you didn't take any of that power back
to yourself
you didn't go for that purpose see that
star in the distance
and and somehow i've done it kind of
right that's all i would say on that
kind of right
so those are the tools i wanted to give
you i want you to i want you to thrive
in this freaking thing
but i wanted the word dystopia or
dystopian in there because that's what
it feels like like what would a
dystopian future feel like
a dystopian future would feel like tech
companies that can control what you say
and when you say it and who you say to
an administration that lies
about absolutely everything the
destruction of language
right the erasure of history we remove
aunt jemima we get rid of tv shows
all of these things are exactly what
dystopian future is all about read any
philip k
dick movie book or watch any philip k
dick movie
um so that was that really was the idea
behind this
and and then we had a couple other
versions where it was going to be a
little more of a dystopian landscape and
we were gonna do a little sort of
synthwave kind of you know the future
that never quite arrived kind of thing
but i just love this i i really i really
really just love it there it is
and as i said guys it is up for pre-sale
little radio reset for you i was a radio
guy back in the day on the siriusxm
go to don'tburnthiscountry.com you can
order from your favorite retailer
whether it's amazon or barnes noble
whatever it might be
and then we've got a link right down
there i want to sign book
plates for you today we've got them
right here
look at this i'm signing
while i'm live someone's going to get
that and if you are a member of locals
you're getting the
the numbered ones everyone else is
getting the non-numbered but
still good still pretty pretty pretty
good
okay uh quick shout out to reuben port
community member craig h
it's your 58th birthday happy birthday
brother appreciate the support
uh caroline says when does the book tour
start so the book is coming out on april
12th am i right april 12th of 2022
i want to start the book tour that day
that day
i want a tour and i want to start here
in los angeles maybe we'll do it at the
orpheum theater which is where we did
the shows with jordan
although it is downtown and downtown los
angeles is basically like a war zone
uh so not downtown can we uh put on the
list somewhere else besides downtown
i don't you know it's like walking dead
down there i don't want to go down there
something out of downtown
but what i'd love to do actually is is
start the tour in los angeles and end
the tour in new york i mean basically
just go across america and we'll have to
bounce up to the pacific northwest and
we'll have to go down to florida at the
end
but really just go across the country i
you guys know this i
freaking loved every single minute of
that tour with jordan peterson
i loved being on the road i love being
in the cars i love flying i love saying
hi to people i love doing
the signings i love doing the meet and
greets i just want to get back out there
i miss it
i really miss it so much just in the
last couple days you know i was in south
dakota for freedom fest
and to just get out there and do a book
signing and i gave a big talk
a couple thousand people we did a
special luncheon for about 80 people
like i like you guys i'm i really do
i like meeting people i miss human
beings i like seeing people with smiles
on their faces and
and you know usually people say nice
things to me and that's nice most people
like get nice things said to them so the
book tour will start i hope
we're working on it now but i hope it
will start on april 12
2022 and by the way you know i didn't
get to tour the first book so the fact
that don't burn this book did so well
i was supposed to be on a book tour i
mean that's really where you sell a lot
of books because then all the people
come and you can sign
your handshake and a picture but we
crushed it despite that but i really did
miss that
uh would love someone to consider the
reuben report t-shirts
we would definitely buy them we've got a
reuben report store
if i'm not mistaken we're doing a little
revamp of it in september is the store
still open right now or did we
it's 50 50. there might be a reuben
report store i think there is but we're
doing a revamp in september
that a lot i've had a lot going on you
know anyway so i haven't checked the
store today
you might be able to find the store
online but if not we're going to
relaunch it
in in september hang on i need a little
liquid
cassie says how can the far left not see
the end result of the path that they are
trying to force us down
when a book like 1984 exists we are
practically
mirroring it in this time your thoughts
please well first off if you want my
full thoughts on 1984
and exactly how uh
how prescient it was relative to what's
happening right now i did a prageru book
club with michael knows all about 1984.
so you can find that on the prageru
channel but yes all the things that i
talked about before the double speak the
destruction
of language no one saying anything
honest people working meaning
meaningless jobs and just going from day
to day it's all here
the state looking down on all of us
right like no one knowing history or
truth
it's all here it is in our face it is
happening right now
and i would say we have a limited window
a a
shrinking window to stop it
i i actually believe that that's where
we're at at this moment and
don't take my word for it take twitter's
word for it twitter which
suspended me last night for
misinformation only to admit
this morning that it was a mistake but
we know that they obviously wouldn't
have done that
if i was just a random person plenty of
people get booted off twitter and have
no recourse fortunately i
have some level of an ability to get my
voice out there
mostly thanks to locals but thanks to a
couple other good people who i gave
shout outs
to before but yeah we are entering a
very weird 1984
time the the collusion
the collusion between big tech
between corporate media and the
democratic party has become
the most important thing to fight period
i don't care what our political
differences are
i genuinely don't you could st you could
be a progressive and really think you
want to tax everybody into oblivion
or regulate everybody into oblivion or
whatever it might be whatever i disagree
with you on right you could be for nine
month abortions some of the crazy stuff
that the left is
for now 15 minimum wage free pre-k and
pre
college for everybody yes like i want to
send people to state schools to learn
like you're going to learn anything
you'll you'll learn
to be a bernie brainwashed buffoon but
bernie brainwash buffoon let's use that
for something else
um but whatever our political
differences are
that is completely at this point
secondary to our inability
to feel like we're communicating fairly
and honestly
uh to making sure that algorithms aren't
manipulating us we just don't know how
we're being manipulated we don't
we don't we have no idea when you watch
this video when youtube shows you
suggested videos are they trying to
completely change your opinion are they
trying to strengthen your opinion when
you tweet something out
and i see this all the time now i tweet
something out it gets thousands of
retweets so
thousands of people agree in essence
then i have to look and the first 50
comments were all horrible things by all
anonymous accounts saying
you know awful stuff to me and then i
always have to click more and then
suddenly there's hundreds of people
saying nice things
so are they reordering things to make
more controversy up top
are they hiding tweets in the first
place like we just don't know so we're
in 1984.
okay we're in it now but we've got
hope we've always got a chance humans
have been through far worse than this
and this is what the human experience is
about like maybe we were all
sleepwalking before january 2020 maybe
we were all just like
too comfortable in in what the world was
and it was slowly slipping away and we
didn't realize it and now we're all
seeing it
so this is sort of like you know you're
red pill that you see reality you see
reality as it is and we've got major
problems
and then the question from reality is
are you going to be white-pilled or
black-pilled
black pill is oh i give up like there's
no way we can defeat this and
big tech and and all of this stuff and
they're going to kick us off payment
processors and it's all terrible
or there's the white pill which is that
humans
have fixed things before and we will fix
things again and we will build better
things and we will build better schools
and we will build better institutions
and all of those things and i think
we're going to do it and i'm going to do
it and i hope you'll do it
and that's all i've got to say about
that kathleen says what positions in a
reuben administration with
these people hold greg gutfeld michael
knowles ben shapiro rick redell and
glenn beck
i had a little lead time on this one
because i got this question and our
locals exclusive but we thought
we thought we'd do it again because it's
just fun so look press secretary i'm
going noles i think knowles has just
become an absolute all-star
of ideas uh his last book speechless
speechless was just fantastic
and he would know how to fight with
depressed people and he would do it in a
fun
in a fun way greg gutfeld he's like me
he likes getting out on the road
i think transportation secretary now i
know you have to be gay for it if you're
in the biden administration
gay pete got it i don't know that well i
know that greg's not gay maybe he was
bicurious a long time ago we'd have to
find out
to see if he's fully qualified to be
transportation secretary that would be
one
uh let's see education secretary of
education
uh we're going to throw that to shapiro
right like facts don't care about your
feelings that's all he would have to do
they'd be like mr secretary do you want
to teach the children critical race
series facts don't care about it
that's not gonna break your feelings um
let's see
uh what would he do here uh secretary of
defense
uh you know what i'm gonna throw that
one to glenn beck glenn beck is a he's
sort of a small
libertarian very much in line with me he
wants a strong
proud prepared military like i do i
absolutely believe in
in funding the military and making it so
strong that nobody's going to mess with
us but at the same time
we don't want a nation build we don't
want to do these crazy wars in gallivant
around the world and pretend we're the
police but we do know that we have a
special place in this world i think
glenn would be
absolutely fantastic on that one and uh
let's see
foreign minister um you know
or secretary of state something like
that i throw that to rick grinnell you
know he was our ambassador to germany he
pissed off
all of the right people and he's just
he's just a great guy
and you know to have such a high level
person also be gay it would cause heads
to explode not that anyone cares
nobody cares what your sexuality is
except the lefties
uh patrick says do you already have a
candidate for the third don't burn title
my suggestion is don't burn this
tomahawk i love it so i do have an idea
i actually really love that one
and i should tell you that david's
working on a cookbook we're actually
kind of working on it together so don't
burn this tomahawk is pretty spectacular
actually
um but if you don't know what patrick's
talking about i've been making these
well we make a lot of different stakes
but my favorite steak to make
is like a three or three and a half
pound tomahawk with the big fred
flintstone style bone you gotta
you know throw it over the shoulder and
walk to wilma and get in the
car and the car flips over and dino and
bam bam and the whole thing
um but we've been making some great
tomahawks i i posted uh some pictures in
locals last week
i got a big green egg for my birthday
this is that awesome smoker i'm sure
many of you have seen it
or used it so you basically slow cook
right
indirect heat for a couple hours on that
thing
and then you take the plate off so the
heat is now the coals are coming the
heat's coming
and then you do a caveman style you just
throw the tomahawk or that whatever the
piece of meat you have is
directly on the coals for about a minute
minute and a half on each side
to get that awesome char and you will
get the most beautiful delicious
steak ever by the way you can go to
davidscookbook.com i'm in major
promotion mode today
you can go to davidscookbook.com to see
some of the recipes that we're eating
and see some of the things that david is
making
and yeah as i said cookbook on the way
uh reminder guys go to don't burn this
country.com
let's get to number one on movers and
shakers are we there yet are we there
yet don't make me attack these people
go to don't burn this country.com you
can buy it on amazon you can buy it on
barnes noble bunch of other retailers
and i'm signing every single copy
that we sell today book plates for all
of you good people
there you are here i'll even sign one
right now they've reuben
extra ones they're all here they're
ready to go uh
boxer says will clyde be joining you
guys on your beach getaway congrats on
the new book and have a great time we
will miss you
uh so we are going we're doing a beach
situation for a little bit
we're going to escape and i just really
i want to catch up on a little reading
but more than anything else
i want to do some exercise in the
morning i want to eat right i want to
enjoy some good tequila and wine at
night i want to
get a good sweat on i want to get you
know some vitamin d in the skin and i
want to just stare out at the ocean
that's really what i want to do for
a good bulk of this off the grid time i
mean it's truly this is about
restoration this is about reset oh and
speaking of that
um we are putting up content right here
on youtube throughout the month you know
i didn't want to do it actually my gut
feeling was you know if i'm taking
the month then i'd love to give my guys
the month and i and i don't want to
overload everybody with politics and the
madness
and the current events and the craziness
of the day uh throughout the month
however if we really went dark on
youtube it could completely destroy the
channel because the algorithm always
wants new content more and more and more
and more
so all we're doing throughout the month
we felt we had to do something
but we're not doing anything political
we are doing shows
about health and digital detox and
restoration all that stuff
so next week we already taped it i've
got eckhart tolle who i've had on the
show before who was
there's almost no words to describe this
guy he is one of the most enlightened
decent evolved human beings on the
planet obviously wrote the power of now
which is one of the
best-selling books of all time really
all about being in the moment we talk
about digital
detox i've got ben greenfield who's a
lifestyle expert we talk all about diet
and exercise
matthew walker an entire episode about
sleep and why it's important and some of
the habits that you can get into and how
to break some of your bad habits
so just like a little bit of stuff to
hopefully help you enjoy the summer and
then
enjoy the fall after that uh all right
we're gonna go to josh
hey dave just curious if there's been a
locals community started by someone that
you didn't expect or that surprised you
um well i can tell you this there's a
bunch of lefty uh
communities on locals and that's just
fine i didn't build
locals we didn't build locals to just
say okay these are communities built by
people who dave reuben likes
or who like dave rubin it's like there
are lefties on there who i know have
you know political opinions that are
complete polar opposite of mine but what
we're doing
the best way i would describe locals is
we are building digital homes
you could disagree with me and i still
think you have a right to have a home a
place where you can have your stuff
you know your clothes your shoes your
toys
in this case your video your audio your
data et cetera et cetera so we're just
building homes we're a home builder
i guess what somebody built this house
that i'm sitting in right now
in my office and then what i do in this
house has nothing to do with them
so that's really what we're trying to do
with locals and it's a bottom-up way of
looking at
at the internet and i think it's the
right way to look about look at all of
these things
and that's another reason why i'm so
thrilled to be partnering with rumble as
i said before we will be the official
subscription
partner of rumble so everyone that is a
creator on rumble
will have a button to connect their
locals community and you will be able to
take questions
from your local community you will be
able to be supported and funded by your
local community
it's exactly what we built for me it was
like well can we can we copy that and
spin it off for other people
and the answer is yes uh joe says when
you first sat down to write this book
what did you want most people to know
after reading did that change oh that's
a good one
that's a good one well first the way it
started was i i talked to the penguin
guys because the
don't burn this book did so well and
they were like you know we'd love you to
do another one
and i was kind of like you know the
world was in a very weird place because
of covid and lockdowns and i had just
done you know a digital book tour but
basically
every day from like 8 a.m to 8 p.m for
two months i was pretty much sitting in
my garage just talking to people about
the book and i sort of wanted like a
little bit of a break so we had like a
semi-break
in august of last year we didn't go away
or anything we did move
which moving is is quite stressful
actually um
but i had a little bit of a break you
know just to kind of reset and then when
i came back in the fall i was like all
right i think i can do this
and my feeling was i didn't want to do
my greatest hits you know one of the
things that i find
to be somewhat tough about doing a daily
show that i do for you guys is
i don't want to just be doing my daily
my my greatest hits you know i left the
left you know what i think about bernie
in aoc you know about that
i don't want to just repeat those things
and sometimes in a daily show it's like
you kind of have to repeat some stuff
like it's just it's just sort of what it
is
but i thought what would be what would
be the new ideas like if you took don't
burn this book and the ideas i believe
in well that's one thing okay and now i
hopefully
i armed you with some stats in that book
i i hopefully
allowed you to think for yourself right
that was the subtitle of the book
thinking for yourself in an age of
unreason
we went from an age of unreason into
awoke dystopia which is the
the subtitle of this book i thought well
all right if let's say you
think that don't burn this book and the
ideas in there were pretty decent
well what are the things that you can
now do in your life and that's really
what this book is about so i think the
first book
is really about ideas and the second
book really is about
action whether it's what you can do to
make yourself less reliant on big tech
what you can do to make yourself
less reliant on on big pharma on big
food you know garden know how to change
a tire
know how to do some basic electronics
basic wiring things like that
um and then and then really well you
know
i don't want to do it i've got i've got
all the chapters right here i don't want
to give them away i was going to give
them away and everybody said no but here
i'll just randomly
pick one you know i i think what i do in
this book is give a really great
defense of capitalism which is on the
ropes i gave a little bit of a
defensive capitalism obviously in the
first book um
and then and then there's a lot about
the digital stuff there really is a lot
about the digital stuff because it's not
just
the data they're taking and that all of
us could be booted it's also what this
whole thing has done to us
we're all very different we're all very
different than we were
20 years ago the way we react to each
other the way we stare at the devices
all the time that's obviously deeply
connected to why i get off the grid so
your question was
was it easier to write than your first
um not really in the first one i didn't
even know
how to do it wrong sort of so i was just
writing and writing and writing and
writing and
i told you this i i uh be start my day
basically at 7 am i'd go into my office
i'd be writing and then it would
literally be 3 p.m
and david would have liked like i was in
solitary confinement he would like
throw a plate with some eggs on it and i
would eat real quick and then and then
when i was done i was done
so i didn't even know how to make
mistakes on that one this one is a
little more technical it's a little more
research heavy there's a little more
anecdotal stuff
so it's just a different thing and what
did you want most people to know
after reading and did that change no it
didn't change
i want you to be more reliant on
yourself
i want you to be less reliant on the
government and less relying on big tech
and i think i i'm pretty sure we
accomplished that here reminder guys go
don't burn this country
dot com pick up the book you get it on
amazon barnes and noble wherever you
want i'm signing
every single copy today you will get a
book plate
today the link for the book plate once
you buy the book
is in the youtube description how we
doing on that amazon right now did we
get to number one come on
we did not yet we're still at number two
what are you people doing to me
help me out here help a brother out uh
we're getting there and by the way
if we get to number one that's great if
we stay at number two that's fine buy
the book wherever you want to get the
book i know some people don't want to
buy on amazon it's all good
no matter what like we already know that
this is very successful we saw some
numbers this morning
it's all good all good uh greg was this
book
oh no we did that one that's greg we did
that one give me something else over
there
um oh crystal we need some baby updates
um
so unfortunately i don't have great news
in that department
um we our surrogate actually ended up
having
two miscarriages which really after the
second
miscarriage um our fertility doctor
wants to use another surrogate and it's
really unfortunate because the
the girl who was our series she's a
great girl and i hope we'll remain
you know friends forever and and all
that stuff but we've had to get a new
surrogate and then the whole process is
just it's just
long and it's slow and covid has really
complicated it
um but it will happen i appreciate the
question
and we're kind of ready you know i'm 45.
i'm i'm going to be an old dad
one way or another david's a little a
little younger but i want to be able to
play catch with that kid
um you know and i want to be able to to
do all the things that
a father should do with a son or a
daughter or a
well we'll let the kid pick their gender
but the point is
you know it's funny on the pick their
gender thing it's like when you're doing
in vitro
you know what they do is basically you
know they take
the sperm i went into a room and i had
to take care of business so
that's how they get the sperm okay i did
that on the first day of lockdown have i
told this story before i don't know if
i've ever fully told this story publicly
on the first day of lockdown last year
um
i had oh i haven't i don't know that
i've told this story i think we actually
cut this out of the book because it was
getting a little long-winded so i'll
give it to you real quick
first day of lockdown last year we were
we were in the process of
of the surrogacy thing and we were like
oh we're going to do the sperm in like a
week or two
but then our doctor called us and he's
like there's these lockdowns coming we
don't know when we're going to open up
again
like you got to get here asap so we jump
in the car
we had about a 20 25 minute drive to the
sperm
to the fertility clinic sperm bank
whatever you want to call it
a lot of sperm over there and uh and you
could feel the tension on the street
like people were driving like crazy it
was like an oddly windy day
in los angeles and it was just like
there was just tension right like
lockdowns what's gonna happen do you
have food in your fridge everyone's
freaking out
we get i open up the door when we park
and i look at my phone my phone rings
it's donald trump jr
he was talking to me wanted to talk to
me what i thought about lockdowns so now
i'm on the phone with the president's
son we're walking and david's like get
off the phone
get off the bun we got to give sperm and
i'm like it's the president's son we got
to talk to him
we're walking in we get to the door of
the fertility clinic and dennis rodman
is standing there
dennis rodman on a scooter is standing
outside the door of the fertility clinic
i don't know if he was given sperm i
don't know if he's just hanging out by
the the sperm bank
or whatever but i was like this is a
moment i will always remember we're in
lockdowns whatever the hell that is
i'm about to give sperm i'm talking to
the president's son dennis rodman's
standing right there
yadda yadda i took care of business it
all worked out so we've got plenty of
sperm
uh but joking aside we're uh we're
trying to
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen
that's really the best i can give you oh
but on the
on the gender part you know it's
interesting because you know once they
have the sperm and then we have an egg
donor so we have an egg donor who's
separate from the surrogate right
the surrogate carries the baby it's
someone else's egg and we have the sperm
okay our hope is to have two kids one
from david and one for me
the interesting thing where you really
just learn what the obvious truths are
about biology
is um you know they get the sperm they
get the egg
they put those things together it's a
blastocyst for a couple days but within
about three days
you know the sex you know the sex they
go
okay it's a male we got eight males we
got four females
we got one and one we got all males we
got all females they don't say oh
there's no difference between these
things like there's obvious biological
difference
so that's another one of the reasons
when i hear all these crazy debates it's
like i'm going through something right
now where i know a very
i know very intimately what uh reality
is uh
okay uh matthew says what do you think
about federal employee vax mandate
announcement made by president biden
yesterday
i mean i'm completely 100 absolutely
against it
it's a little unclear to me whether it's
constitutional and it's a little unclear
whether he actually was saying they're
gonna do it for sure
but this is what they do with everything
they lead with some authoritarian thing
and then they just wait for people to
get dumb and tired enough
to go ahead and do it i don't i just my
personal belief
for as long as we live in a free country
which is tenuous at best
my personal belief is that the
government especially the federal
government
should not be allowed to force you to
get an injection of
any kind that's just what i believe
i think you have to make the decisions
that are best for yourself i have a
feeling if they do this federal
uh employee vax mandate that there's
going to be a lot of pushback and i
think a lot of people
might quit or retire and they'll just
get on unemployment and maybe that's
what the government wants it's putting
everyone else on unemployment
but i think it's deeply dangerous and i
also think
what's really happening here is we're
just seeing an
endless move of what the goal posts are
right
so it was two weeks to flatten the curve
that it was oh maybe we'll have a
vaccine and by the way
many of the people who are now all
provacs were against vax's
when trump was uh you know the one that
was actually making it happen with
project warp speed we did a story a
couple days ago
all the hosts on msnbc with their old
tweets joy reid is the all-star of that
basically saying who could ever trust
the cdc again and trump is evil and all
that stuff and
chris matt chris hayes also had tweets
like that and
uh maddow she even still no one even
talks about her anymore she's still
going um so
it's like they just moved the goal post
where it's like oh we weren't for
something when it was this guy now we're
for it
i don't think you can do a federal mask
federal vax
mandate like that just seems like a
crazy thing and it's also
did we flatten the curve or not why does
no one ever bring that up
is is covid roughly 98 to 99
of people will survive kobe the answer
to that is yes
don't take my for it do a little
searching for yourself
then we were told the vaccines were 95
effective now we're finding out studies
that it's significantly less than that
or maybe that they weren't supposed to
prevent kobe the new one is
they weren't supposed to prevent kobe
they were supposed to prevent you from
getting a worse type of kovid
or less symptoms that's not what we were
promised so you know fauci saying masks
do everything then saying masks don't do
anything then saying we played the video
the other day
oh masks make it much worse because you
fiddle with your face much more now he's
for a mass mandate again it's like
wait a minute were you lying or not
whether you touch your face a lot like
that doesn't change
based on science like come on man that's
my biden impression come on man
megan what books will you read off the
grid so we have a list we actually have
a stack of books i don't even know
what's in the stack so i had
asked the locals community
to send me non-fiction books i didn't
want to do
i didn't want to do sorry to send me
fiction books i didn't want to do
non-fiction
i didn't want to do just like
biographies and history and that kind of
stuff i really wanted to do fiction like
and i mostly like sci-fi
so people give us a bunch of
recommendations we we went out and we
bought a whole bunch of stuff they're
all they're all in the other room right
now
but i think what i'm going to do is for
the first couple days i'm just going to
do nothing
i mean i really mean that do some cardio
i'll lift a little bit
relax and then i'll i'll get into some
reading probably in the middle of the
month
reminder guys don't burn this
country.com
you can pick your retailer you can get
a signed book plate of my new book which
is really part two and what i'm now
i'm now promising to be a trilogy i am
the george lucas of burning
okay um you the link is down below so
once you buy the book you can just
submit your information
we're signing book plates don't burn
this country they're right here
and there you go tal says what are you
most looking forward to
during your time off i mean it really
it's the easy answer is just like the
general
relaxation like just the generalness but
i would say at a different level it's
like
i know that that those last couple days
what has happened in the four years that
i've done this thing
is that those last few days when i have
to come back
i do start thinking about like all the
craziness of the world again and i
started thinking about tech again and
the news and
all the lockdowns and like all the
nuttiness even before last year just
whatever the craziness of the day was
and i really feel like and you could
probably go back and look if you want to
see some of my
september shows where i come back last
year we did it with michael knowles i
think we did it with glenn beck the year
before two years
i think twice we did it with ben shapiro
if i'm not mistaken i feel refreshed i
feel
like oh i have fresh eyes to look at the
world that's why this thing feels
important to me
because i think we could all use some
fresh eyes right now like we all had a
problem
with big tech and social media addiction
and being endlessly stuck in the fight
we all had a problem with that
before kovid but in covid i mean think
about it this way
since covid are you online more or less
every single person's more and if that
you had been asked
before covid would you like to be online
more or less everyone would have said
less
so we all knew we had a problem then the
problem got worse and no one's getting
out of the problem so that's why
i do this and just have what i mean by
fresh eyes are just a little
space a little space to allow new
thoughts to come in one of the things
that i talk about with eckhart tolle
you'll see it next week
is that it's not just that we're being
slammed with information all the time
it's that you know back in the day
remember when you used to meet a friend
at the bar
let's say and what you do it was before
cell phones you'd be like okay i'll meet
you at the bar i'll meet at the corner
at eight o'clock right meet you on uh
23rd and fifth at eight o'clock
well then you'd show up and you didn't
have a phone back in the old days
and then if your friend was late you
would just kind of stand there you'd
stand there and you'd kind of look
around and you'd see people and
one of for me one of the great things of
living in new york city was people
watching right you could stand there and
you
or you'd think or you'd stare at stare
at the sky or stare at your shoes
we used to have built-in space to our
day-to-day lives
we no longer have that because
everywhere you go first off you're
texting with the people you're going to
meet the entire time
if somebody's late you're tweeting
you're distracted you're watching
youtube videos we never give ourselves
when's the last time you did it really
like just some time to just not be doing
any of that stuff to just
stare out into the abyss to stare at the
ocean to look at a view
whatever it might be you know to drink a
glass of wine and not be
talking about politics or whatever it's
getting harder and harder and
and i think those giving yourself that
space is as
important as not being on the things
like just that that ability
to just be like oh maybe maybe
um the brain needs a little breathing
room maybe there's some new thoughts
that are trying to get
in but they're constantly blocked out by
algorithms and the day-to-day doom
scrolling i think it's possible
uh let's see who at locals should write
the check to jack at twitter for all the
free pr
oh jack dorsey jack dorsey you had
agreed to
be interviewed by me many times over the
years and it never happened i suspect it
ain't gonna happen at all
at this point although my buddy and
locals investor anthony pompliano has
said he will try to set it up
look i'd love to talk to jack you know i
look i have harsh words for the guy at
some level
but at another level and i would say
this for for mark zuckerberg or any of
the people
that run these tech companies in some
ways they're just all over their head
mark zuckerberg i mean if any of you saw
the facebook movie from you know what
was that 15 years ago
it's like he was a kid who was basically
trying to get laid and then figured out
a way to create this little college
website to get laid
next thing you know he's like the most
powerful man on earth so
i don't have sympathy like he's got
obviously like an extraordinary life and
every resource known to man and
wealth that is beyond unimaginable and
all of those things but i have a little
sympathy for like you creating something
and then sort of losing control of that
creation
and that's not to say he's made all the
decisions right although i think
zuckerberg in this case has been much
better on some free speech stuff
basically saying we're not here to
police everything
aoc tried when he was under oath to
basically be like you know you have to
do what we want and he was like well
that's actually unconstitutional because
you're the government and i can't so i
have more sympathies with zuckerberg
than i do with jack dorsey but i don't i
my gut feeling is he's probably not like
a fully evil human being how about that
and i would like to talk about some of
these inconsistencies and how you can
flag me for misinformation and suspend
me
and then you know just the next day
basically say oh that was a mistake and
why
all the mistakes always are on
conservatives or right leaving people
and never the other way around and how
many people have been unjustly banned
from these things
and by the way i can also say that you
know from starting locals like none of
these questions are easy how you're
going to deal
with free speech and how you're going to
deal you know with harassment
and how you're going to deal with if
people start putting
porn or whatever whatever it is whatever
it is like i believe that companies are
allowed to make decisions on their own
so there's there's just so many things
that we could actually talk about
i suspect he won't and one of the
reasons he doesn't really do press
anymore is because you remember he was
on rogan
with tim poole and he really came off as
as not really knowing what was going on
at the company
he also was the ceo of another company
what's the other company that square i
think
i'm pretty sure he's the ceo of square
as well try to imagine what the
day-to-day operations of a guy that's
running twitter is
and he's also the ceo of another company
how does that make any sense
like i know for me i'm running i'm doing
the reuben report and i'm
you know i'm co-founder of locals i'm
not running locals i'm not the ceo
my partner soft is running the company i
know what kind of wherewithal and work
that takes um
but like running two companies seems
like really weird so yeah he's the ceo
of ceo of both locals and of square
which is a payment they're a payment
processor i suppose yeah
um okay let's see oh i got a whole bunch
of tv hits today in case you're not sick
of hearing me talk i will be on oan with
natalie harp
at 1 40 p.m pacific i will be on newsmax
with sean spicer and lindsey keith at 3
10 pacific
and then i will be on fox news prime
time at 4
30 pacific and then to end my day
i am busting out that big green egg and
we got a porterhouse we got a juicy
juicy porterhouse that we are going to
slow cook
and then we're going to do caveman style
as i said before
and then and then tomorrow although
my public life will end online tonight
until september 1st
i will have my phone tomorrow just to d
not for news or anything
like that but just i gotta we have some
travel plans and i got to coordinate
some things and
you know things like that but but sunday
sunday it fully begins
in earnest uh karen says what author has
inspired your writing the most
ooh that's a good one i haven't gotten
that before well
look of course the easy answer is jordan
at some level
because but i will give you another
answer jordan's the easy one because he
gave me advice right at the beginning i
was
i was in we were in oslo
when i got the book offer we were about
to go on stage it was one of the biggest
shows we were doing it was about two
minutes to show time
and i got the call we got the offer and
you know one of jordan's
uh rules in the original 12 rules in
effect is you know have friends that are
happy for you
basically i'm paraphrasing here and i
walked into jordan's green room and his
wife was in there
and david was with me and i said jordan
i just got the book deal we just closed
it and he
lit up his huge smile he
slapped his hands he spun around in his
chair he got up he hugged me he was so
happy
and then he immediately in just perfect
jordan style immediately was like here's
how he here's you
you have to write you have to write each
sentence four times and you have to have
two monitors
so he gave me some technical advice he
was i tried to do the two
the righties sentence a couple times
thing it was not for me at all
um so everyone has to figure out your
way to do it but i think he he inspired
me in that he got me to really do it
and it was partly being on tour that got
the deal in the first place but in terms
of
let me see i really want to get this
question right i really want to get this
right
i'm going to peek over here for a second
i could probably give you a couple
answers on this um but i'll say this
you know glenn beck from reading a
couple of his books
you know there's a sort of whimsical
nature in some of them
that i really have liked you know even
when you're talking about serious uh
topics so his last book how is it how to
fight with socialists
uh arguing with socialists that one's
really sort of almost like an
over-the-top sort of
humorous sort of light book but what
i've always felt and i think it's why i
try to do this show the way i do
is that there's a way to talk about
serious stuff about censorship and about
assaults on freedom and encroaching
authoritarianism
there's a way to do it i think i just
did it where
you can talk about it in a somewhat
amusing way a somewhat fun way you can
still
realize that you have to live and that's
what i really tried to do
with don't burn this book we had to
remove a lot of jokes because i had it
way more jokey than it was but i loved
hearing from people that they were
laughing while they were reading it
i was a little more controlled i think
with the jokes in this book and i will
tell you that for don't burn this
country
which you can get right now don't burn
thiscountry.com there is only one star
wars reference
there is only one and i only had two we
only cut one
you know my feelings about star wars it
has been butchered horribly
i didn't want to do too many there's one
star wars reference
that's it uh devin says have you ever
had withdrawals during
your off the grid well there's that
weird tension the first couple days like
oh man did i make a mistake what's gonna
happen
i can imagine this year it's going to
feel really weird like suddenly in the
last day or so we're talking about
lockdowns again lockdowns which we know
don't work
so am i going to come back on the grid
and california will have been locked
down for the month will businesses be
open are people going to be outside
um you know we are going away for a
little bit so it's like
when i get back uh if i'm able to
you know avoid everything while i'm away
you know what happens when i
come back i'm on a plane i get in a car
and there's no cars on the street i
might be able
to deduce that you know the lockdowns
have begun or that
we're in the middle of a lockdown or
that the zombie apocalypse is here or
there's been an emp search i mean who
the hell knows
um but yeah there's always a little bit
of tension those first few days because
we're just so
used to it we're so used to grabbing our
phone we're so used to eating lunch
while we're reading this stuff so
there's a little bit of that but after
it's usually about three or four days
then then like the space starts coming
in and it feels good and there's a
calmness and a and a decency
and you know we're all running around
this you know this hamster cage
doing this to our brains all the time
right that's what we're all doing all
the time
somebody else's thought oh my god
somebody had a thought another thought i
mean that's what twitter is
thought thought thought thought you
can't believe how many idiots there are
but it's like there were always a lot of
idiots we just didn't follow them
now we follow all these idiots thought
thought i'm a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ]
yeah so if you can get past that part of
it
then it starts becoming fun and then
there's a moment there's always a moment
around day 16
day 18 something like that where it's
like should i go back at all
should i just call you know john galt it
right now that's it
i'm i'm out i'm out i'm done but then i
do come back and i will come back this
year and as i said i do think this is
going to be the craziest of all of them
because because
the first couple years that i did it
there was you know there was crazy
politics stuff but it was like yeah
america is going to be fine like
one way or another but now it feels like
everything is just on like this like
hairline fracture that could just like
just erupt into a giant chasm
so that that does feel different this
year it's like what what would surprise
me as i said it would be like biden step
down would that surprise me no
um if they were if all the blue states
were locked down would that surprise me
no um if they told us that
china was actually it was exposed that
china has been running a giant
misinformation campaign in america and
it's been fueled by twitter and all the
things would that surprise me
no like nothing would surprise me so
that that's a weird thing to come back
to this year
which feels bigger than other years past
where there was like basic parameters
where now we have like sort of no rules
anymore uh chad says
who is his front runner in the
california governor recall election and
who will you be endorsing 100
without question if i say anything
crystal clear
larry elder 100 has my endorsement he is
my friend i interviewed him here last
week i saw him up at
freedom fest in south dakota he is a
good man he has lived his life for this
very moment
he did not want to do this i assure you
larry's got a great
gig he's got a great life his
girlfriend's awesome he's fun
he's happy there's so many other things
he could be doing he's successful
on other fronts right with with his
radio show and everything else
he's doing this by pure by calling like
like somebody's got to fix it and i've
got to be the guy
i really believe if every if those other
candidates just over the next couple of
weeks
oh and and of course this is one of the
things i'm going to miss uh in the next
month but if
if over the course of august a bunch of
those people the caitlyn jenner thing is
caitlyn jenner is in freaking australia
right now shooting big brother it's a
sham
and a pr stunt and she should be
embarrassed okay and everyone with
everyone involved in that campaign
should be absolutely embarrassed
all right um but if if the other people
running against newsom can just be like
you know what
elder's got the momentum and there is a
much bigger fish to fry here
uh we've got to get rid of news if they
can all coalesce behind him
and if he can get one debate if they'll
even agree to a debate and larry can get
on stage with that evil
disney cartoon villain that is gavin
newsom
larry can make some moves i also think
that california as crazy as it is the
average person in california is more in
line
with larry's political beliefs that are
very much in line with mine he describes
himself as a small l
libertarian obviously he was a trump
supporter he doesn't want lockdowns he
wants to lower taxes
it's going to be a big slog even if he
becomes governor because we've got
really a one-party state here
but anything will be better than gavin
newsom
um so my hope is that that larry can
bring the fight to gavin and then as i
said if it doesn't happen if larry loses
if
if newsom is reinstated or or wins the
recall whatever it is uh i'll make some
decisions
at that point uh ken says how long did
it take for you to write the new book
um well it's a little hard to say like
the chunk of the writing it was about
three months
so pretty much from where the end of
july now is pretty much like
february march april um but
the editing process like we still just
sort of finished the editing last week
and i still have actually till september
15th to do my like final final final
edit
so what i'm gonna do while i'm gone is
i'm taking the the digital copy
obviously that i have now and it's gonna
be the first time we're actually gonna
print it i've always
i've been reading it off my computer
which is not the best way to read these
things but we're gonna print it out i'm
going to take a sharpie and a
highlighter
and i'm really going to go through for
those last couple edits and then i'll
come back and i'll
talk to my editor and we'll we'll get it
sort of fully
fully lined up i still have to write a
little bit of the
the intro as i said i want to change
because of what happened with twitter
and then i have to write the
acknowledgements and
a few other things like that guys what
are we doing here well it's my last day
on the internet until september 1st
2021 my new book don't burn this country
surviving and thriving in our woke
dystopia and i assure you that's what
we're in
is up for pre-sale right now and
if you buy it today i am signing book
plates for every single person that buys
it today all you got to do
is go to don't burn thiscountry.com the
links for your favorite retailer are
right there and then we have a link in
this youtube description right down
below
where you submit your information so
that we will mail you the book plate
you will then place the book plate in
your book
and life will be good uh patty
says are you leaving your staff a
guacamole fund for their chipotle when
you're gone for a month
enjoy your time off you know what you
know what you guys have been busting
your butts
for the last couple weeks chipotle on me
for the month
not just the not just the guac i'm not
kidding every chipotle you order for
this month
and connor all he eats is chipotle it's
gonna be a lot cheaper for you
michael because he you eat other things
but he's like 99
the guy's half chipotle at this point uh
i will pay for all your chipotle for
this month
unlimited chipotle on me done uh storm
says what hobby are you picking up
during off the grid well
one thing i can tell you you know i've
told you guys about my torn acl and my
knee so i got prp
it's when they spin your blood around
they get the plasma out they inject it
back into you it's really good for your
cells and regeneration
so i did it about two months ago my knee
is feeling better that it's felt in
years and years so i'm i'm playing
basketball again which is really nice i
can't fully play in like a five on five
like really all out game but i can do
some half court kind of stuff and move
around a little bit
i'm thinking about the surgery i know a
lot of people are telling me to just go
get it
and i have a great doctor who is who's
worked on a lot of nba players and he
assures me that if i got the surgery and
i did the rehab right i'd be better
better than before even though i'm a
couple years older but it's a it's a
long recovery and it's like i'm
fairly busy and if i was going to do it
it was going to be august and i was like
wait a minute am i going to lead
up to all of this just to be basically
incapacitated for the month so we're
trying to figure out what to do
so so basketball and hobby-wise what
else hobby-wise
you know what i really i'm not going to
do much of this or no maybe i will
um you guys know i've been doing a lot
of gardening lately and we've got this
really cool rooftop planter situation
it can be tough here in l.a when it gets
you know we could have days in a row
where it's like high 90s
and you know you need a little shade and
we've got a water stuff a lot but we're
growing tomatoes and peppers
and cucumbers and we got some lettuces
and uh we got some herbs and all sorts
of stuff
up there um so i think i'm gonna refresh
the entire thing actually because
we've got some burnage i was just up
there this morning and it's been it's
been hot
lately doug says is locals looking to
alternative payment methods i want to
dump paypal yes
i promise you whatever your concerns are
on the tech side of locals
nobody has solved all of this stuff yet
and what i mean by that nobody has fully
solved decentralized storage yet
nobody has solved fully the payment
processor stuff and by the way
you know when you say okay well
everything should be decentralized
meaning all of the data should live on a
million people's computers so it exists
forever
it's like do you really want that what
if somebody puts child porn up there do
we really want that
so there's all sorts of that's why i say
it's like there's legal issues there's
philosophical
issues there's technical and
technological issues and we have to
figure out
all of those things and we're working on
it so yes we're working on more payment
processors
we're working on the storage stuff you
know i can't lead
too much about what we're doing with
rumble but this partnership that i
mentioned before this is just the
beginning the idea that we're the
official
subscription partner of locals the idea
being locals
is you know the youtube replacement
where the patreon replacement we're now
tied together
and it's just the beginning but i kind
of can't say more than that at the
moment it's like we will do this
we will fight these guys and they will
rue the day
that they ban dave rubin on the twitter
ali says are you recording an audio
version of your book yes absolutely
obviously it's not scheduled yet because
we've got to put the final final touches
on the editing
but i loved loved loved loved doing the
audiobook it was so fun we did it
in the course about four days i had to
go across town and you go into a booth
and you've got somebody in your ear
making sure you pronounce all the words
right and make sure the names are fully
right make sure you don't
you know slur something or stammer or
whatever it might be
you've got the engineer with you right
in there but i loved it because i was
able to give a little more personality
to it i think i was able to hit the
punch lines in the right way
um i don't know that i'm supposed to say
this but i did change a couple
words uh over the course of doing the
audio book things that i just thought
felt read a little you know read one way
and and verbally once you're saying them
were a little bit different but i love
doing it and i can't wait to do it again
courtney are you going to tour college
campuses again i hope so i mean i don't
know what's going on on college campuses
and
you know lord only knows where things
will be at in the fall my main goal is
to tour
toward the book as i said starting in
april but what i really want to do is i
want to start doing some big theater
shows
you know do less kind of you know i sold
out a lot of stand-up clubs over the
last couple years and
for those of you that have seen me do
stand-ups like i got like three jokes
but i get up there and i have fun with
you guys and people have a ball
um but i want to do more theater stuff
like really kind of
big theater events um so we're gonna
look into that we'll probably start some
stuff in florida hopefully
in the fall just a moment
kim says o'reilly has the killing series
do you want to create a burn series yeah
i mean
it's happening whether i want it or not
right so don't burn this book don't burn
this country
we have an idea for the third one as i
said i got a cookbook coming so you can
kind of
read into that what you will i shouldn't
say it's my cookbook if david's got a
cookbook i'll have a little something to
do with it
and then i think there's all sorts of
other things related to the name of a
tour
and all sorts of that stuff uh ian oh
this is a good one if larry elder wins
and he offers you a job in his
administration would you take it
um let me say this if larry elder wins
first off i will be the happiest guy in
all of california
i will be happier than larry elder i
assure you that if he offered me a job
i would consider doing some sort
of part-time maybe press job dealing
with some of the [ __ ] nonsensical
borderline evil press that he would have
to put up with the liars
in the newsrooms and dealing with you
know it would become then a mainstream
story the interesting thing right now
is that even though the governor of the
largest state in the union is being
recalled nobody's covering it in
national media
they are getting a little nervous though
because there are more and more stories
being written about larry
um but you know once cnn starts going
after him once washington post new york
times et cetera starts going after him
then we'll know that there's really a
move being made which will which will be
a nice moment
i would maybe add a at a first off i
wouldn't want money for it i do not want
money i don't want money from the people
and i don't want money from larry
but just out of pure like i'm in this
with you man let's fix this freaking
place
i would maybe do some kind of part-time
press secretary thing if you wanted
um but we shall see i i hope i am
presented with that
with that problem uh why is there such
as is amy why is there such a fuss about
people
choosing to be unvaccinated shouldn't
they have the same legal right to refuse
treatment of course they should
we've been told for the last couple of
years my body my choice and now we're
being told
my body your choice none of this makes
any sense right
none of it is is logical or consistent
with things that we were told we had to
believe otherwise we were right-wing
racist maniacs a year ago when trump was
in office
um again and i and i am not a scientist
and i
i'm not pretending to be anything other
than i am but we do know
basic things about covid you know this
98 to 99
recovery rate especially if you aren't
you know 80 years old and don't have
other comorbidities other
sicknesses and things like that that
virtually everyone uh
survives perfectly fine i have plenty of
people in my family and friends that got
kovid
that all were sick for a couple days
some were barely sick some with a little
bit of a sniffle some a little bit more
sore throat
i know one person had a really
excruciating headache for a couple days
but they all got
got better now that's not to say
everyone does but the point is
why would every single person this is
never what we were promised and that's
what i mean about the moving goal posts
we were never promised oh we'll never
open up again or we will constantly be
threatening you with masks and lockdowns
until
everybody is vaccinated that every
federal employee is vaccinated
and every member of the military is in
back is vaccinated we're going to make
sure that your job knows about your
vaccination
status it's like these guys lied to us
about everything every big story in the
last couple of years you know at
kavanaugh and covington
and russia hoax and jesse they lie
about absolutely everything and then
this is the thing that we have to have
absolute trust in them and we can't
question anything like does that make
sense i don't mean that as a
conspiracy theorist in like a
traditional sense of conspiracy theory
i mean it as just as like a logical
decent person why are we being told
we're not allowed
to make decisions for ourselves and our
family
why is that why do you really think that
they care about you
so much the same people who you know
wrecked your job
who locked you in your house who who lie
to you all the time
they care about your health so much they
care about yourselves and they just want
to keep you
safe like does that make sense to
anybody to anybody
let me know in the comments right down
below uh
jesus or jesus says i found about you
recently on tim cass that's tim poole's
podcast and just ordered your book
and he plans to have tim poole back on
the show yeah tim's been on a couple
times
tim is as close i would say to a to a
real journalist as possible he used to
be out in the field a lot more he was
tracking antifa
and he used to do more as far as i know
like out
on the ground reporting so i don't know
if he calls himself
a conventional journalist anymore he's
doing a little more of what i do it's a
little more of like a daily like
here's what i think about the world
here's here's my lens and hopefully you
can
glean some information about that um but
tim is a good guy
he's welcome back anytime i know he's
wanted to do more in person so usually
on his show it's when everybody's in
person i think
is he in connecticut if i'm not mistaken
or maybe he's in dc now i know he's
somewhere east coast but next time i'm
back there maybe i can
jump on his show and he's he's
absolutely welcome back anytime
vic says can you sell prints of the book
cover art statue of liberty on fire
can we talk to somebody we got a guy we
can talk to all right we got a guy we
can talk to see what we can do on that
one
meredith says are there any movies that
you plan on watching while off the grid
so i should clarify
i will be avoiding news and current
events and all that stuff but i'm
i am okay watching some movies right
like i'm not this isn't about i can't
see anything digital or electronic
whatsoever like i will get in my car
there will be gps there there's no point
in me
having a month off the grid only to get
lost going to the supermarket
um so that i'll have gps in that regard
and i'll uh
yes at night we'll probably watch some
movies um
we've been trying to do quiet place too
and just we've been so busy the last
little while but i really enjoyed the
first one so we'll we'll probably get to
that maybe
maybe even on saturday night as our our
first night off
um is there anything else that i really
want to
see or i'm looking forward to right now
i don't know david's got a note
in his iphone about all the movies that
we've been trying to catch up on
um but i i can tell you again it's sort
of like on the book front
it's not going to be political stuff
like it'll be some sci-fi stuff or some
some like kind of light stuff but
that'll be
absolutely it um earl says have you read
ben shapiro's new book yet
his new book the authoritarian moment
well i just interviewed ben it went up
this week
um i will be truth be told i read about
half
of the first chapter and then i skimmed
around before the interview
as you can imagine this week has just
been completely crazy on all fronts
and you know i've said i've tried to
always be upfront about this when i
started the show
if i was interviewing somebody about a
book i really tried to always read the
book and i always did probably for the
first year or so
since then because my life and my
businesses and everything else have
become
much more hectic it's rare that i can
read the full book occasionally i can i
did with
douglas murray's last book but it's but
it's pretty rare that i fully can
so i usually have my guys try to give me
some sort of
synopsis of the book or i will bounce
around and figure out what i think is
best but i also think as an interviewer
sometimes knowing a little bit less
is actually better because then you can
answer you can ask
less leading questions you can ask more
broad questions
and and let the author kind of fill in
the blanks for you
so you know it's 50 50 and i think
there's probably some cases where
knowing more is better
in some cases knowing less is better
beth says what retailers should we
pre-order the book from i don't want to
support amazon and bezos i think that's
totally fine if you don't want to
wherever whatever makes you
comfortable can you read me the list or
can you give me the list of
uh if you go to don't burn this
country.com it's going to redirect you
to the penguin random house website and
they've got links there to a bunch of
different
retailers so amazon is on there i know
that barnes noble is on there
michael's giving me a couple couple of
them right now bookshop is on there
apple books is on there
audible is on there uh and then you know
one of the things that we're gonna do
i don't think we're doing it right now
is bookshop the the are they the
conglomerate of the small bookstores
so i think if i'm not mistaken so i'm
doing some of this on the fly obviously
bookshop if i'm not mistaken they're
like a conglomerate of small local
bookstores and i try to support
small local bookstores as much as
possible so i get it you know sometimes
the ease of amazon is is great
but we'd like to keep some small
businesses
operating as well ben says does the book
address
faith in any aspect or is this book more
secular advice
you know one of the interesting things i
think about the first book
is that i did address faith and i said
that liberalism
does not work without belief that's
thought of as more of a conservative
belief and perhaps that's why
maybe i'm more conservative at this
point i don't mind if someone says that
i'm conservative i actually think that
shows the wide
tent of conservatism um
but a lot of sort of traditional
liberals
were not happy about that and i know
that even even some of my friends
were not happy about that because what
do you mean dave if you're talking about
belief that's conservative what are you
saying that religion has some value
that's conservative are you saying
time tested eternal beliefs have some
value the stories of the bible have some
value
that got a certain amount of uh liberal
people upset not everybody but a certain
amount
but to me what's happening in our
society right now
is a purely secular society on steroids
where we
worship science and i believe in science
of course i believe in the science when
the science is properly communicated to
us everything we're doing is through
science
i'm looking at a camera how'd that get
there you're watching me on the internet
how'd that happen
you know like science cool stuff um
but we're at the end of worshiping
science where any given day there's a
study that says this we better do this
there's a study that says that we better
do that
that thing's wrong this thing's right
and and then and by the way the
same science people also there's no
biological differences between males and
females i mean
it's all become sort of crazy so i
absolutely do believe that
belief i believe that belief is a key
part of a functioning society that by
the way is what most of the founders
believed
even though they were trying to separate
church and state and they all had their
own different struggles with religion
and
um was it thomas jefferson i think was
writing a version of the bible where he
was removing references to god if i'm
not mistaken
um so i think that there's all
there's all of these ways we can look at
this but your question the question was
actually was there is there stuff about
belief in here
just quickly running through the the
chapters right now there's uh yeah
yeah yeah there's a there's a little bit
but it's not
um it's not to tell you what to believe
or that you have to believe this
religion
specifically but i i do get into why i
think
tradition is important uh why i think
that you know time-tested ideals are
important and that is really a nod to
religion
oh just to be clear thomas jefferson
wrote a bible without jesus not god
pretty close considering i've got a lot
going on guys what are we doing here
radio reset for you
my new book don't burn this country is
out for pre-sale
today surviving and thriving in our woke
dystopia
you can go to don't burntthiscountry.com
you can get it at your favorite retailer
and i am signing book plates for every
single copy
sold today this is u.s only we're going
to have some other promotions for our
international
readers and viewers later but that was
the only thing we could pull off
for today and uh and then i go off the
grid in just a few
hours from now holy my my throat's
starting to get raw i can feel it
uh when's the last date and time we can
get a signed copy it's today only
midnight pacific
today only that's it if you want to sign
a numbered copy that's what we're doing
for the locals people so that's locals
exclusive
but yes signed a number it's anyone that
watches it today not just not just
during this live stream
it's anyone that buys it and submits the
form today so as long as
the form that's in our youtube
description uh youtube description down
below
as long as you submit that by midnight
tonight pacific you'll get the sign a
numbered copy
and then by the way uh i'm not going to
be doing like crazy promotions
for the book like this really is a
one-time thing uh
when the book comes out in april that
day we'll do some fun stuff with
with some signature stuff and all that
but but if you do it if you buy the book
the day the book comes out obviously
you're not getting it
that day this way you're ensuring that
you get the book that day
um sam says what's your take on leaving
big cities and moving to small towns to
be more free man
tell you this sam my family has had and
actually there is a little bit about
this in the new book
my family at times since around 1910 has
had dozens of family
members in new york city and in the
boroughs i was born in brooklyn
my my dad grew up in brooklyn my mom
grew up in the suburbs of new york city
but my grandparents all lived in in
manhattan and brooklyn for the most part
um i go into a little bit of that in the
previous book as well but dozens of
family members
new york city lower east side like the
the the eastern immigrant
story that so many of us know and
experience whether you're italian or
irish or jewish or whatever it is
a greek doesn't matter or some other
thing all doesn't matter like what that
what that true american story is all
about like coming here with nothing and
then
living in in tenement houses and then
eventually
living in a maybe a nicer walk-up
apartment but then eventually getting
out to the suburbs and all that like
that is what my family's story is
it's one of the reasons i'm so
appreciative for this country um
but we have one cousin left that's it
my sister and her husband and two kids
lived in new york city they left during
the lockdowns they're down in florida
now
we got one cousin left i may have to
call the a team an airlifter out
um what
what that's it that's messed up
but i got one cousin left yeah that's it
because so
to your point like it doesn't seem like
the city thing is gonna work
at least cities that are run by
democrats because as long as they're
going to defund the police as long as
they're as long as they're going to give
a nod
to crime as long as they're going to
also be teaching
all of the worst things and we're going
to put critical race theory in all these
schools and all those things like how
how can you rely on that how could you
if you wanted to open a pizza shop
in new york city how would you open a
pizza shop and have a big glass window
in the front of your pizza shop knowing
that
some antifa guy could come and punch it
or throw a brick through it and break
the window and no one's going to do
anything like the cost benefit of living
in new york city doesn't work anymore
and i say that with great sadness
actually like my my formative adult life
was in new york city from around
i moved to new york city in uh in the
end of 99 and i lived in new york city
until
2013. i was in new york city for 9 11.
like i loved loved that city the endless
all the stuff that i hated about the
city in retrospect i loved like the the
smells and the heat and the subway and
the grossness and the
people and the anger and the love and
it's all nuts new york city but if you
can make it there you can make it
anywhere and i think that
that stuff got into me and helped me do
what i do right now and living in a city
that is a truly international city i
think
maybe i didn't even realize it at the
time but i think maybe has helped me
come to some of the ideas that i believe
in now because i believe that we can be
a multicultural
society in the best sense that's what we
are and it's only
it's only the identity politics people
that are now trying to turn
us against each other because of skin
color and all of that stuff where
if we live in new york city nobody cares
nobody oh there's a black guy walking
down the street nobody cares no
there's a gay guy walking down the
street nobody cares there's a lesbian
with a lazy eye and a limp nobody cares
she's latino too who cares and that's
what that's what america is all about um
so i but broadly speaking i would say
yeah get out of cities it sucks it
really sucks like
it'd be great to go back to lincoln
center and
and hear an opera i'm not even a huge
opera guy but i did that once it was
awesome uh
you know to go back to central park like
these would all be awesome things but is
it going to be safe who's going to
really run this thing like you've got to
get rid of
every democrat and then maybe it would
be time to go back um
congratulations on the new book how many
copies of don't burn this book
sold at launch i remember you and
candace owens having a friendly wager
um i don't know that i'm fully at uh
privy to say what the answer to that is
i will say
i'm a man of my word candace did sell
more books week one and i am completely
completely fine with that there was a
little tension there at one time because
candace's book
we had announced my book first but then
it looked like kansas was going to come
out the week before
and i was like oh you know that's
because how many people are going to buy
two books from you know we're in similar
worlds obviously and i
absolutely adore candace i love candace
she's doing such great stuff and
and i'm so thrilled for her rise and i
think she can do
unimaginable things going forward but
but her book was going to come out a
week before i was like oh that kind of
sucks like why'd they do that but then
they ended up
pushing her book she did do she did sell
more copies for sure
i'm not i'm not denying it um but we did
great we did great and by the way i love
competition i really do like i love the
fact that around the time my book
came out glenn beck's the last book that
i referenced earlier came out a little
bit before that douglas murray's book
came out a little bit before that the
the fact that
i'm in this game where people that i
know and like are doing good things
and i just believe like we'll all rise
together it's not about you know
michael jordan was michael jordan
scottie pippen's still pretty good
you know bill weddington not so good but
he was on the team he did some good
stuff too and got a couple rings like
you can figure out your
place in the wider world and i like the
idea of thinking about things sort of
through a team
a team aspect uh james oh ron says can
larry elder really save california i
think we've addressed this already i
think it's possible
i think it's possible like if i didn't
think it was possible then what the hell
would i be doing with my life why would
i be interviewing him why would i be
talking about the ideas i believe in
like
even in a crazy state anything can
happen and remember this
just think back to election night 2016.
i was on air with the daily wire guys
and andrew clavin said something to me
that really has stuck with me since then
and i've credited him with this many
times since
when it was happening when we started
realizing trump was going to win and
suddenly some of the states started
rolling in it was like holy [ __ ] the
thing that nobody thought could happen
is about to happen
orange man is going to be president
hillary who is being handed everything
is not going to be president and at that
time i had voted for gary johnson i
wasn't happy with either one of those
candidates obviously my feelings on
trump changed
but like we were watching it happen in
real time and when it fully
got announced even though if you don't
if you remember hillary didn't concede
that night remember that she didn't
concede until the next morning i guess
she's a conspiracy theorist or something
like that she also sent out a tweet
a little bit later saying that trump was
an illegitimate president but back then
you were allowed to do that stuff you
know
um but clavin said something that really
stuck with me
he said and i don't think he was really
for trump either at that point he
definitely wasn't for
clinton but he said do you he looked and
it was me and shapiro and jeremy boring
was in there and knowles was in there
and he looked at all this and he said
hey
do you guys realize that only in america
could this happen the thing that nobody
thought could happen
just happened that shows you the
flexibility and the beauty of what a
free system really is
because there's always a chance so to
liken that to larry elder
there's always a chance and by the way
these things do happen in free societies
you know what
even though clavin said only in america
it's like brexit happened everyone said
it couldn't happen
free societies as long as there's a
little air for freedom
can do some pretty extraordinary things
james says will the book tour be just in
the states would love to see you in
spain i would
absolutely love love love love to go to
spain i've never been to spain
david actually spent a semester in spain
and just absolutely loved it
we were gonna do a stop with jordan on
tour in spain and then some travel
things got a little screwy
as i said before i didn't get to do any
book tour for don't burn this book i
will go
basically everywhere basically anywhere
they'll take me
except portland who wants to go to
portland that's a pretty
big [ __ ] uh i'll go to portland
we'll need more security for that show
um but i'll pretty much go anywhere and
i would love to go to spain i haven't
done much of western europe
i really also want to go back to italy i
haven't done italy since 1997 when i was
a poor college student
and i was eating big macs the whole time
i didn't appreciate food i didn't have
any money i didn't
appreciate good wine so i really want to
go back to italy i really want to go to
greece
i want to go to poland i want to go to
hungary like i want to get out there and
and if i have a book tour as an excuse
that would that would be pretty sweet
quick radio reset guys my book don't
burn this country
is out for pre-sale right now i want to
sign every single copy
even if i end up with the claw by the
end of the day
remember the claw if i end up with that
claw it's okay
uh that's what i want to do don't burn
this country.com pick your favorite
retailer buy the book today we're
signing book plates for every single
person
us only the link where you can submit
for the book plate is right down in the
description
keep talking dave keep going you can do
it jan says
how did society get to this place where
the needs of the few outweigh the needs
of the many
education you know a couple years back
when i started talking about what was
wrong with the left and i started going
to college events and i was
showing up to talk about basic liberal
stuff and i was being called a white
supremacist and a nazi and a homophobe
and a whole bunch of other stuff
i started noticing the trend the trend
that now everybody sees
and i remember very specifically the
first event that it really hit me
how rotten something was we were up at
uh well portland state no surprise
and my friend peter bogosian who's
obviously been on the show many times
he is i believe at the time was an
associate pro professor of
uh psychology no of philosophy at the
school
and i was doing an event with uh pete
christina summers you all know christina
hop summers who's the original factual
feminist
she's been fighting for first first wave
feminism and true equality her whole
life
so you have pete who is uh he wrote a
book at that time called a manual for
creating atheists we have this atheist
philosophy professor lefty
you have christina an original feminist
in essence an old school lefty an
old-school liberal
and you have dave rubin who was you know
a year off the young turks still calling
myself a lefty and all that
you have a bunch of us to come to this
event to talk about free speech
we go to the event there's tons of
antifa there they're calling in bomb
threats they're blocking people from
going in there's a ton of security
i remember they had to keep us in a room
off site
before and there was security standing
outside the door
and christina is just a lovely lovely
lovely woman and i just adore her and
she's very dainty if you ever meet
christina she's very dainty her wrists
are like this and i remember i we were
being shuffled from the room with
security to the event and i was holding
her hand and
thinking how how small her hand was and
i was like this is nuts like
we're the good guys what's going on here
why are these people
they're calling us nazis like this is
insane and they're calling us homophobes
and
and christina hates women and you know
all of this insanity
and we gave a talk i think it was
interrupted once or twice but not too
terrible in the room itself but i
remember they had to shuffle us out
after
they didn't want us to go we all wanted
to go out to eat but they didn't want us
to go out to eat near campus after it
was a whole thing
by the way at that event that was the
first night i met a guy by the name of
andy
no yeah that andy no andy no was
was i think he might have even been a
student at portland state if i'm not
mistaken at times but in essence he was
a student journalist
who again he was a lefty himself
and he started doing some journalism
actually saying there's something going
on with this antifa thing like what is
this socialist
thing what is happening here and we all
started seeing it
from that point forward and i would talk
about it on the show and then obviously
you know i brought on people like brett
weinstein who was a lefty
at evergreen state and because he said
that we shouldn't have a day where we
tell white people not to come to campus
he was called a racist basically he and
his wife wife heather hein were
basically chased off campus and had to
lose their jobs over this
um you know the james damore incident at
google
uh lindsey shepherd up at wilford
laurier university fighting you know she
tried to as a
student ta tried to show a class at a
jordan peterson video and she was
basically suspended for it even though
she made no
commentary about the video she just
wanted people to watch it
so there were all these things that a
whole bunch of us saw were wrong
and they're directly correlated to the
marxist quote that you gave me there
like college and and now we're seeing it
actually that it's leaked into high
school and it's leaked into junior high
and in some ways it's even leaked into
into elementary school and preschool
these ridiculous
awful the worst time tested ideas of
equity instead of equality and taking
from some
and and and being embarrassed by success
and that jealousy is a virtue
and all of these things we've decided to
make these things good i
i would lay a lot of this blame on
bernie he somehow tricked an entire
generation of young people
to think that if just the system does
everything for you
whatever you want it to do for you and
if the system just gives you everything
that things will be good and that's why
liberalism has nothing to do with modern
progressivism
jfk asked not what the country can do
for you ask what you can do for your
country he was a liberal democrat
president that's completely the opposite
of bernie sanders
free college for everybody free health
care for everybody
we're going to tell you that the minimum
wage is fifteen dollars even though
everybody's going to be replaced by
ipads okay three discs free that
he doesn't it's not because he wants
things to be free because he's such a
great guy he knows in his heart of heart
i have no doubt
that if we had free actual universal
healthcare the way he wants it that
service would go down which is why
people still come to the united states
right now
to take part in our evil capitalist
system that is by the way
it could be better for sure but people
still come here because they're on long
ass lines in canada for all sorts of
services
in their socialized medicine system and
if you don't believe me on that
uh talk to lauren chen who's a friend
and a former guest on the reuben report
whose father
uh developed cancer could not for months
get the appointments he wanted i was
able to connect him with a fan of mine
uh who was a longtime supporter i'm not
going to
give him a mention his name right now
just in case he doesn't want to
but who worked at one of the best cancer
institutes in the united states and we
were able to get
her father here and he's doing much
better from what i understand so why did
he want to come here instead of canada's
socialized medicine system so so these
people have
all the wrong ideas but they've tricked
they've tricked young people into
thinking that all the wrong ideas are
the right ideas
i gave a talk right before the 2016
election
at crossroads school here in los angeles
this is like
the most elite high school in los
angeles
it proc can you see if we can find a
price on it it probably costs 50 grand
a year to get students to high school
it's insane this is where all the
hollywood moguls send their kids all the
hollywood elite
all the super rich people send their
kids and right before the election they
wanted to do
they wanted to have a liberal a
libertarian a conservative a socialist
all come and debate
and talk about who they were going to
vote for and things like that they
brought me on as the liberal and i of
course ended up agreeing mostly with the
the libertarian
but they had this socialist there i
don't even remember his name it was a
socialist
who um he was a socialist
who actually ended up running on the
socialist ticket and a lot of the kids
were applauding him
a lot of the kids were plotting him and
then i went all in and had to rip them
apart and then by the end i had a lot of
the teachers nodding with me and
everything else
crossroads school in la harvard high
school in la which i'm getting some
numbers on right now is 42
000 a year for high school i'm looking
for crossroads i think it's maybe in
santa monica we'll check on that
so we have to fight these bad ideas and
by the way these bad ideas aren't going
anywhere
this is why we have to fund students
instead of schools right
we have to be able to give people more
school choice why does elizabeth warren
hate school choice
and hate charter schools while she sends
her own kids
to private school this is a woman who
also pretended to be a
native american to get a job to get a
professorship right we know that she did
this
they lie about everything crossroads
school is 38 000
a year so it's a deal because harvard
high school is 42 000. oh
we have an updated number crossroads is
45 000 so i guess the deal
disappeared so much for that deal uh
let's see
okay uh oh my god is that right so the
first number that i read 38
000 was for elementary school at
crossroads elementary at crossroads can
you imagine 38
000 a year to send your children to some
elite school where they're going to be
brainwashed by some asexual marxist
what's wrong with you
kathleen says sign book plates what
about paw print of clyde available for
extra that would be fun
that would be fun maybe we'll do
something around that uh when we get
closer
to uh to actual launch uh let's see
uh dave does your book cover the
subtlety the left is using to lull
people into the collectivist mindset
it's less about that honestly i mean
that's sort of what i was just talking
about for the last few minutes
it's less about that because that's
really more what don't burn this book
was about like exposing the left for
what it is why the ideas are wrong
why funneling money endlessly to
programs like affirmative action don't
work
and keep people in a cycle of poverty
all that so i i think i did
that job there again this book is more
about the action that you can do to be
more reliant on yourself
to be more reliant on your local
community to understand and think
clearly about your relationship with big
tech things of that nature
more than like i'm trying to move past
the why i left the left i left the left
and then i lit the match and that's it
no more left okay vin says do you think
the universal mail in ballot will affect
the california news and recall
so they're forcing basically a mail-in
ballot and from what i understand rick
rennell's doing a lot of work on this
um there is deep deep corruption with
the
voter rolls here in california lots of
dead people a lot of people that have
moved
a lot of people who are ineligible to
vote for one way or another
so that right there is so broken and
corrupt that that's one of the reasons i
said before it's like larry
elder has a massive uh hill to climb
here because it's not just oh i got the
better ideas i have to get more people
to vote for me
it's like if the voter rolls are all
screwed up and then we do all this stuff
with with mail and ballots and you don't
have to show your id which you don't
have to do in
in california although strangely if you
were to get on a plane to leave
california you have to show your id so
is that racist by the way do you have to
show an id to get a covid
vaccine you probably uh
you probably do they put your name on a
piece of paper racist
[ __ ] that they are that woman
at cvs racist asked for your id when you
got the coven vaccine
uh all right we got about 20 minutes
left guys man i am talking today
uh sally says is this book
is this book good to give on the fence
liberals like the last one yes
it is because my hope is if you gave the
last book
to an on the fence liberal and i know a
lot of you did we got a lot of emails
like that like
people saying you know i gave this to my
cousin i gave this to my wife i had one
guy he kept saying i kept putting it on
my wife's nightstand
for like six months and she kept
removing it and finally one night
or he woke up one morning and it was
actually it was flipped over it was open
a couple pages in
um yes it is because it's the next
extension of that because my hope would
be
that if you if you gave this to a sort
of
self-hostage liberal or an on the fence
liberal whatever you want to call that
that they would have woken up to some of
the ideas and if they have
this is the next step part two empire
strikes back
we're putting han solo in carbonite you
know what i mean don't burn
thiscountry.com guys you can get the
books
at uh amazon barnes and noble
a couple other places if you just go to
that website don't burn this country.com
we've got the links right there and the
link right down below you just submit
some information that you
confirm that you that you purchased the
book and we're gonna send you a signed
book plate ellie says what do you say to
friends who are still afraid to leave
their home
my friend who's vaccinated told me that
she's terrified because adele's a
variant
stop watching the news i mean i try to
tell this to people but it's hard like
once they're in that mindset
when you're in that mindset where like
you're just watching and cnn
you know they're showing you death
tallies which remember cnn had like a
rolling death tally throughout the trump
administration then biden became
president they
they don't have the death valley now
they're trying to scare us again
so i'm guessing that any day now they're
going to have charts they won't show
numbers because the numbers are actually
quite low
but they'll show percentage increases
which as i said if you go from one to
two it's 100 increase
um you got to try to wake them up
however you know how
literally be like do you want to take a
walk like start with that
do you want to take a walk and let's
just take our masks off and go for a
walk or
you keep your mask on let's go for a
walk like we i'm sure that the rates of
agoraphobia the fear of leaving the
house
the rate of being afraid of just basic
social interactions you know one of the
things i've really really noticed in the
last couple of months where i've
traveled more
is that um airline stewards is it's it's
there's a tension on planes right now
there's a rudeness
i saw a flight attendant get into a
fight with a guy and it was not
the passengers fault and they actually
kicked all of us off the plane and i had
to leave
take a flight back from miami we had to
drive to fort lauderdale and get on
another plane all together
so i think sort of basic social stuff is
breaking down again that's why i go off
the grid
i'm going to see real humans for a month
i'm going to talk to real human beings
i'm going to talk to cashiers i'm going
to i'm going to talk
to to waiters or maybe i won't talk to
anybody
but it'll be better than the other thing
uh kurt how about we disband the
department of education yeah i'd have
absolutely no problem what is it doing
what is it doing other than brainwashing
people brainwashing young people to turn
on america
disbanded destroy it disband the
teachers union
randy weingarten that woman is a
complete maniac disbanded sorry you
should have no control
or influence over anyone's life again i
don't have kids yet so maybe at some
level it's
it's easy for me to say um and and when
we do have kids you know
god willing we'll have the resources to
be able to send our kids to to private
schools or charter schools or whatever
it is
but that's why you got to push for
funding students instead of systems
because then it'll give the parents the
flexibility and that's as i said before
it's exactly why the left doesn't want
it
they hate choice because they want
brainwashing
that's that is it is as simple as that
it is as
simple as that all right four questions
left and then i have
well i have 18 other media appearances
to do but i think i'm going to
not talk i'm going to sit in a dark room
for a little while um johnny can you
implement a no
suit jacket rule for you when you're
chatting with us on the private
livestream on locals
yeah we can do that no suit i don't
think i've done any with the jacket on
well this morning i did because we did
it from the studio if i'm out of the
studio
you got a deal my man if i'm out of the
studio no suit jacket i'm usually in a
t-shirt
last night i was wearing just a regular
shirt button down
but the policy has been instated can we
make note of that
make note of that in the report mc how
will you know if new lockdowns are
imposed if you're off the grid i won't
know
i won't my goal is to not know uh
it is very possible that for a week i
will be in my house and everyone else
will be in their house and i will be in
my house by choice and they will not be
in their house by choice
i don't want to know as i said we are
going away for a little bit so when i
get back
and i get off the plane if the airport
is like completely empty i think i will
have gleaned something out of that
but i'm going to try to avoid as many of
those interactions as possible
i'm going to work out here at home
instead of going to the gym because i
want to avoid the tvs anyway
i'm going to do as much as i can to just
make sure i don't get any of that stuff
and
and we have a very short list of way
well we have
a very simple way of that people can get
in touch with us meaning family and
things and it's a very short list
related mostly to health
related things if people absolutely need
to get in touch with us but it's not
i mean really like if if biden announces
his retirement i don't want to know
like or if barack obama slips and
accidentally says oh we got to get rid
of joe kamala you're in
i don't want to know i'll find out on
september 1st the world will continue
conor says best guess on what was on
biden's chin in that video banana
pudding
if you didn't see this like five minutes
before we started this live stream
there's a video going viral right now
where biden
is giving he's sitting at a desk and uh
they hand him a note his people hand him
a note and you can actually see there
are close-ups of the screenshot
where they it says something like sir
there's something on your face
and it looks like he has like a little
goo over here and he wipes it off
and then he sort of eats it like i don't
know what it was maybe his face was
melting i don't know what's going on
there it's just all so ridiculous
uh all right guys we got one more
question for you uh michael says give us
a little hope before signing off for
august look
we have hope andy dufresne
shawshank redemption hope like that's
it's the most human thing that there is
hope and the belief that we can change
things and make things for the better
and that you have some capacity over
your life and that you can fight for a
world that you want to live in
um we have to have hope because guess
what all the people coming to take that
hope away
they believe they believe that that they
can destroy all this thing
so how about the rest of us decide hey
we're not just going to sit back and
take it anymore
that would be my hope to you over the
next month whether you take a couple
days off the grid or whether you're as
engaged as you ever were or whatever it
might be
um fight a little bit more and i don't
mean violently and i don't mean what the
democrats say get in their faces
and don't give them any peace or any of
that stuff that maxine waters or so many
of the democrats have said
but in your own life show up to those
student council meetings
the parent teacher meetings show up say
what you believe go to when you're when
you're
in a whatever your job is and they're
pushing some sort of racist diversity
and inclusion program down your vote say
something
say something it will not get better
unless you say something
no one is coming to save us you know
like
they ain't coming like 20 guys on horses
ain't coming to town
to save us you got a chance to save
yourself and
and i truly i swear i believe this
well everything i've said here i believe
but i really really like in my bones
believe this
if enough of us stood up
within three days we could reset this
entire thing
i actually believe that if enough people
said nope
no more i'm not participating in this
anymore
and then whatever that means to you in
your life whether it's taking your kid
out of a school
whether it's deleting your social media
accounts whether
it's doing something new in business
whether it's moving your family but if
enough people said
that's it we live in a time of lies and
dishonesty and authoritarian [ __ ]
and i will not
play any longer i will not be part of
this
any longer three days that's really what
i think it would take
i honestly believe that that of course
is where a lot of my energy is going to
be spent over the next month sort of
when i'm
when i'm trying to reset some of my
thinking and get those fresh eyes on
things as i said before
and open up that mental space to get
some some new ideas in there and it's
not even new ideas
really get some just a fresh perspective
on what's going on um
that's that's where i'm gonna be that's
where i'm gonna be how can i help
you know i think i think in the last
year
i've helped a lot an awful lot of you
say dave you helped keep me sane it's
the best thing someone can say to me
um you guys have helped keep me sane at
the exact same time especially
those of you on locals because i
communicate with you directly
all the time and i get to see what your
lives are all about and it ain't all
about politics
we we can we can fix this but we got to
do it together it's really as simple as
that
uh guys quick recap on the media hits
today although you've got to be sick of
me maybe get out there take a walk
yourself but if you if you're stuck at
home
and you really just want more if you're
sitting there going i want more dave
more dave please for god's sakes give me
more
more dave moore clip that um
oan i'll be on with natalie harp at 1 40
pacific
uh newsmax i'll be on with sean spicer
and lindsay keith on spicer and co at
310 pacific
and then my last hit the last hit till
september 1st i'll be on fox news
primetime at 4
30 pacific
all right one more time and then i'm
going to say goodbye
don'tburntthiscountry.com
you can buy the book at your favorite
retailer there are links right there and
then
our description right down below has the
link where you can submit your
information so that i can
sign a book plate for you you can put it
in your book
and send it and if you do that if you're
in our locals community to do it there's
a separate link there
and you'll then you'll get a numbered
copy as well
all right let me take one more sip and
then i'm going to give you some final
thoughts
we can fix this
i'm a piece of it you're a piece of it
we're all a piece of it
i hope that this summer whether you take
a day off or a week off or a month off
or no time off
i hope that um you give yourself a
little space
to to be a human in all of this madness
i hope that i'm able to come back
with those fresh eyes i was just talking
about and continue to help give you guys
a little perspective on some of this
stuff that
uh that is okay it is okay and and what
sits next to all this is that for me in
the last year and a half like
it's crazy like we're in crazy times
we're in some sort of cultural
revolution there's no doubt about it
but life has been pretty good for me my
life is pretty good and
and i want to show you or not even show
you that sounds too populous i just want
to be part
of of you realizing that life can be
good within this thing too
because it can be and maybe the best way
for us to win this thing
is just being a little better than those
guys while they're burning
we can be building and while they're
complaining
we can be showing people that there's a
better way to do all this stuff and be
appreciative
of this country and be appreciative of
the people that came before us and the
ideas that allowed us to succeed in all
of those things
so on that note guys i am
saying goodbye i'm a few hours away from
getting off the grid
as i said i'm doing a little little
smoked porterhouse tonight we're going
to crack open a nice bottle of wine
and then i've got a little bit of
travels ahead of me and then i'll just
be hunkered down at home
avoiding the machine and uh i wish you
guys the
a great end of the summer or i guess
we're in the middle of it now i hope you
have a great month in august
i hope you take a little time off for
yourself as i said we'll have some
content here
um and for those of you that are in the
reuben report locals community
i know you'll still be interacting and
talking and all that good stuff
um and i'll catch up on all that when i
get back um so more than anything else i
just thank you guys for being on this
adventure with me
helping me build something that that
allows me to do something as crazy as
what it is that i'm about to do
which shouldn't be that crazy at all yet
in our modern times it is quite crazy
so i thank you guys and
enjoy the rest of your summer and i will
see you on september 1st